good morning believe nation today's
message is work the hardest over to you
Wayne Gretzky professional sports isn't
much different the players who love it
the most and the players who work the
hardest the players who put in the
biggest commitment
they're the ones who ultimately are
successful as athletes and then when
they go into the real world business
world those are the athletes have become
successful is a whole different venture
so there's a very similar sort of
mindset
I was fortunate plays and that's why I
was chosen I don't know
and we focus all your attention on being
the best player you can become and
that's a full-time job I mean your time
to think about life after hockey is like
journeyman hockey if you want to be the
best that you can be your focus is just
the people who win work the hardest
because they love what they do they put
in the hours and the hours any hours any
hours for days and days and days and
weeks and weeks and weeks and months and
months and months years and years and
years because they love it because it's
not worked for them the only way you're
going to be willing to put in the work
that is necessary to win to be the best
in your industry the only way you're
gonna put in that amount of work is
because you love what you're doing and
if you don't you're gonna you're gonna
lose cuz there's gonna be somebody who
will love it
who loves it more than you and will
crush you and you'll you'll be not even
a number two you'll be mediocre because
there's lots of people who love what
they do and there's less people grinding
it and working hard if you are looking
at your calendar like open up your
account look what you're gonna do today
or look what you're doing tomorrow
what's on the schedule if you're looking
at it and you're like oh I'm gonna do
all these things if that's your reaction
you might be in the wrong business now
if it's a one-off thing if there's a one
day you know you got to deal with the
government or something fine but if
that's daily if that's consistent if
that's always happening if you continue
to look at your calendar and you're
you're upset and depressed and angry
you're in the wrong business the work
should feel like something exciting to
go and do where other people might jump
into your schedule and say that's crazy
I could never do that that's great
that's why you're not crushing it like I
am like go go crush it in your field go
do your thing as an example here's one
change that I've made to my youtube
channel you may have noticed this month
the video series look a little different
I'm working with the videographer Jason
and the only way we can make this thing
work was if we did it on one day so I
used to film my videos once a week
on a Wednesday for the week in Jason
works by the day so okay you know what I
want to increase the quality the video
so I wanted to look more Hollywood do we
look more Hollywood this is looking nice
you guys like the quality give a thumbs
up for Jason down in the comments and
the way to make it work was to do it
once a month and so I'm sitting here
filming my videos for the month we're
doing like 70 videos in one day grinding
them through I've got two extra large
coffees got one sitting behind here and
halfway through that and here's a thing
to make this work it's a lot of extra
pressure on my team to get a lot of
things ready and sooner and faster right
so my teams are working extra hard to
get it ready for this one time and if we
continue it it's their usual job it's
not as stressful or hard I'm thinking
about them I don't want them to stress
out too much but really the person who
has the hardest is me because for me
it's not just a one-off thing
this is now gonna be every month like do
I have the ability to stay on to have
energy for an entire day can I get
through making 70 videos in a single day
I don't know but when Jason and I are on
email we're trying to figure this out
and I look at how hard it was gonna be
for me to do to be on camera for that
long I'm like I got to do this this is
awesome
I like crash and burn and like it
doesn't work out and it totally fails
and I can't handle the the the length
and the time but I wanna try where so
many people have a hard time making 1 to
2 videos a month here we are making 70
in a day crushing it all down and I love
it it's hardest on me versus anybody
else on my team but other than think
about it because I love the challenge I
love the ability to work that hard and
see if I can do it and see if it makes
sense for what we're trying to do what
do you guys think you like you like
these videos like this you want more of
it let me know leave a comment and so in
thinking about that I don't think that
I'm super special by the way I just
found a thing that I love doing I'm
willing to put in this kind of hustle
and work because I love making the
videos because I want to create more and
better content
for you guys you could put in that same
amount of drive energy hustle that I'm
doing today in your business but it's
not gonna happen if you look at your
schedule and my are like this I was
looking at my schedule last night and
like I'm so excited about tomorrow I'm
so excited about tomorrow so we like to
see how it goes let's try to crush it
right and again not every day is gonna
be super amazing but you should love the
work that you do net and that you should
be excited about the day that is ahead
net net and not feeling sad depressed
angry frustrated about the work that you
have to do the people who win work the
hardest because they love what they do
so the question they today I'm curious
do you look forward to the day that you
have tomorrow look at your schedule
tomorrow look at what's on the calendar
are you excited about that day I know
it's just a snapshot but I want to know
for tomorrow are you excited and what's
the most interesting exciting thing that
you have on your list leave it down the
comments below and we'll join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to chase chase thank you so
much you're picking up a copy of my book
you're one word it really really really
means a lot to me and I hope you're
enjoying it thank you guys so much for
watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso hey believe nation thank you so
much for watching if you want to learn
more about this subject get a little bit
deeper on it I'm gonna share some extra
bonus clips that I hope you'll enjoy do
you think there were no hurdles or
obstacles that I had to overcome but
even I got to high school I wasn't
ranked as you know I wasn't ranked I
wasn't highly touted as a high school
prospect I had nobody really running
knocking on my door saying please please
please come play for our school until
coach MacKillop called and you know
everything happens for a reason and
there's there's a story into everything
and and if you take time to realize you
know what what your dream is and what
you really want in life no matter what
it is whether it's sports whether it's
in other fields
you have to realize that there's always
work to do and you want to be the
hardest working person in whatever you
do and you'll put yourself in position
to be successful and you have to have a
passion about what you do and basketball
was mine and that's what scared me to
this point the choice you have as an
underdog is if you're gonna choose to
fight and choose to fight to win there
are a series of strategies available to
you but they are all more costly than
the strategies available to the favorite
so I give the example I have a chapter
about it
and a software mogul in Silicon Valley
an Indian guy who coaches his daughters
twelve-year-old daughters basketball
team and they are without talent they
are by his own by his own admission this
was like they didn't know how to barely
know how to play the game he takes them
all the way to the national
championships he does it by he instructs
them they're gonna play the full-court
press every minute of every game and
defend every inch of the court right now
that's actually a very effective
strategy particularly in age class
basketball if you're the underdog it's
your only chance of winning is to play a
really aggressive defense
it requires however that everyone in
your team expend maximum effort every
minute of the game you cannot loaf for
an instant you have to be in really good
shape and you have to run yourself
ragged and you cannot let up most people
will not play that way because it's too
difficult if I said to you we're not
gonna be doing does this elegantly
designed plays and shooting gorgeous
baskets and passing the ball we're just
going to be doing this for the entire
game and you're gonna be exhausted at
the end most kids would say that and
that's not why I signed up so it's like
that's a kind of classic illustration of
that effort effort is the route one of
the routes available to the underdog I
can outwork you even if I may not be
able to outspend you but I can outwork
you well how working is
at all orders not easy to do you know
that's as anyone who has worked in a
startup knows that's this one of the
stressful parts of it but successful
startups I am I've never seen any actual
data on this but do we think the people
working for successful startups work
longer hours than people who work for
fortune 500 companies my guess is yes it
wasn't until I started my own team when
I realized that there are people with
incredible talent and no motivation and
then there are other people that are
willing to work their ass off who don't
have a natural ability but will become
successful because they're so determined
and and I saw it I mean I saw it
especially in a couple of guys that I
first put on the birdhouse team namely
Andrew Reynolds map beach mat Beach was
in my eyes the most naturally talented
skateboarder that I've ever seen
everything came easy to him and I you
know when I would request these guys to
go on tour all I ask them is that they
skate for exhibitions and whatnot Matt
wouldn't skate half the time we'd flown
to Europe I don't have any money then
you know in our company but I was flying
these guys to Europe for competitions he
would go to the contest and not feel
like skating and I was like how can you
do that you know I was just thinking
about not just to me but to yourself
like you have this incredible talent you
just don't care and then I saw Andrew
Reynolds who was the scrappy little guy
taking not very clean but in terms of
his style
but trying some of the hardest stuff
taking the heaviest hits but always
skating off and always trying and he has
become probably the most well respected
street skater today Andrew Reynolds me
he formed Baker Brand Death Wish
skateboards ever the the community of
the the most hardcore skaters these days
call him the boss
because he developed his style because
he worked his ass off and he's the
shining example of hard work